trafficking and slavery prevention month
we want to remind you that it's never
too late to be a shiro the bias shiro
foundation's 7th annual awareness gala
is next month and here to tell us more
our founder kimberly miles and vice
chair gingerland van buren first and
foremost thank you ladies for doing such
important work especially here in las
vegas right which is the leading city
for this type of evil yes yes it's the
number one per capita uh hub of crime
here in las vegas a statistic we should
not be proud of and we are here to
change exactly exactly thank you for
having us of course just introduce us
first you know to be a sheriff the
foundation and what you guys do what
your mission is
well exploited
abandoned and abused young girls so
unfortunately 13 year olds being
prosecuted for prostitution it's
unacceptable in the state of nevada
and the median age is actually um with
with fed federal statistics is 11 years
old is the median age for a sex
trafficking uh youth here in the united
states that is so scary
how do you guys go about saving these
girls
partner with other nonprofit
organizations to help elevate there's no
duplication it's super important to take
what we already have here but we have to
expand on it right you can come to our
website you can find out and learn about
all of our affiliates that are doing
amazing work here in the city themselves
uh there's so many to mention but you
can go on shirofoundation.org
to see all of the great work and all of
the partnerships that we sort of helped
to affiliate here uh who are all
fighting this all fighting this
important fight now speaking of your
partnerships this is what brings us to
the event coming up in february so let's
talk about that yes february 12th
at the sterling club we have an amazing
event it's our seventh annual gala it's
an awareness gala because we need to
keep letting people know how bad the
problem is and how we are here to fix it
so it is our awareness gala and um we
are partnering with um helms helps
foundation they currently have a 20 000
match for us right now
so you can if you're not coming to the
gallet because i know people are like
it's sort of still covered um but you
can go and log on to shirofoundation.org
right there on our homepage is a link 20
bucks turns into 40. five turns into 10.
you know a million turns into two
million absolutely absolutely
tables we're feeding you today that is
a worthy worthy cause worthy cause and
what else in the in the community you
know is coming to help you and stand for
this fight yeah well there's many
different people so we have quite a few
uh philanthropists who have gotten
involved it's our first year which we're
so excited about they have our own
committee for fundraising
congratulations so many different people
living in the turnberry where the
sterling club is has banned together
built three different tables
super excited because we also have lexus
we also have tgig the grove we also have
all-purpose security is one of our big
sponsors is our phoenix awareness so
security is really important when you
come to safety to make the difference i
myself am a survivor turned advocate
people wondered why we got involved with
this you have to speak up you have to
rid yourself of shame and guilt once you
can risk yourself of shame and guilt as
we're at all volunteer organization at
cherylfoundation.org you can hear more
but it's important to tell your story if
you see something say something and get
educated boldly elevating awareness is
what the b-e-a stands for thank you so
much
i want to keep going we have to wrap up
i want to tell people about the gala the
annual shiro awareness gala is happening
february 12th at the sterling club you
can get tickets online at
shirofoundation.org that was so powerful
thank you so much for sharing your story
with everything that you're doing
kendall i will send it to you i love
that